seemed to be an implication in your
first of all great talks really these
are fantastic that we're having these it
Yale so I'm saying this with love the so
the first question is uh I just seem to
get the implication that you were
suggesting that exploratory research
shouldn't be registered and people
should be around and what I believe is
that if you're going to do exploratory
research that's great and we should be
publishing exploratory search we should
declare it as before to research we
should we should register that we're
doing exploratory research and we should
give a message history of that so that I
think that sometimes people don't take a
moment to say what exactly what question
am I actually trying to answer here
because I'm just reflecting on my own
group where the time that they spent
registering should be the time that
they're spent organizing their ideas
about what exactly am i doing and the
registration process shouldn't be
burdensome beyond that but it should
enable them a pause to say it's not just
I've got all this data and let me just
run around but let me take a moment to
say if I'm really a scientist then I
should be able to at least define what
I'm doing even if that definition is
discovery and exploration but but what
question my answer I just wanted your
response to it because it just seems as
almost you said well this will um down
and it discourages them and then you
said then if they get negative results
it's all for naught when actually the
negative results should be informative
and so it's about if you've shaped the
question hey I did this I didn't find
anything next person can build on that
what are your thoughts about the great
so I'll start with the last one which is
so there's a model platt how to science
piece I think 1964 entitled strong
inference and his argument was
scientific field events most quickly
when they posed sort of questions where
an experiment can answer it and either
answer will be informative right so that
that is a model of science and we would
love to have and we should encourage
researchers to find those questions
where any answer you know whether it's a
null or you know whatever the outcome of
the experiment it informs the community
okay that being said the reality is it's
often it that that's not the only model
of scientific inference and
other model is is one where okay another
one another model is one where you're
sort of taking a chance so you might
have a hypothesis that so I'm not
speaking a lot to this last point that
I'll come back first one you have a
hypothesis that I don't believe maybe
one percent of the community believes
your hypothesis I wouldn't put money on
it but you're willing to put some time
into it and if you end up finding
evidence supporting of it then that's a
huge contribution of science because
you've you know moved our beliefs right
our prior was strongly against it you
provided evidence so I think a lot of
work has that character and for that
reason if you find evidence consistent
with what the community already believed
it will be harder to publish in venture
career it should absolutely be published
somewhere it should enter the record
reap roots yeah but the the poor grad
student you know who spent three months
on that would have been better served if
they'd thought of their work more an
exploratory mode because they were not
in a position to see rise ex ante so to
clarify I think of a confirmatory vs
exploratory more as a continuum there is
a there's an edge where you have pure
confirmatory research where you have a
pre analysis plan the codes all written
up and then we really know that the
p-value has the properties or the other
tests have the properties that
statistics says they should have however
we rarely even there with a thorough
pre-registration there's often degrees
of freedom all right research or degrees
of freedom different ways you can
analyze your data and the more degrees
of freedom you have the more possibility
there are that a p-value will be
deflated right because of selection for
it's sort of interesting results so I
think my recommendation is yes caller
should you exploratory analysis they
could do explore to our experiments
rather than feeling obliged to make the
one experiment the experiment but
there's real value to 2 pre-registering
all throughout the continuum just I
think for what you're saying to make it
transparent what the mode of inference
was that I you were adopting I think I
mean I agree actually and I think it's
just declaring this is what I'm doing
and then I want to get that person value
for if it was worth well I just one
quick question on it great talk about
the policies but what do we do in the
policies really
aren't being enforced so you know
there's I mean even in Obama
administration me FOIA information out
of FDA you're going to be wait until
you're old you know it they can talk
about open government but it's not
really when it's coming to FOIA requests
and that it on some hands we've made
progress on other hands we really
haven't and I think it's not consistent
in with regard to take example what's
going to go on p.m. i mean that help the
data holders the health care
institutions are failing to comply with
federal regulations the hitech act 2009
and the government fails to push it
forward so i think it's a question how
we are also advocating for the
government not just to make the policies
but to enforce them so the people can
respect them and ensure that they're
they're being followed anyway i don't
know i don't know that's a city center
which is a question about what can be
done so I'm going to let me say let me
say two things here both of them both of
which are unsatisfactory the first is
that one of the unsatisfactory things is
that there were two parallel processes
that emerged in the Obama administration
one was an open government and open data
process run by one set of actors were
primarily technical people and the other
was a track that was essentially the
FOIA track which is essentially run by
the lawyers and that's one of the
challenges so I would frequently talk to
stakeholders who would say I want data
set X and I would say don't call the
FOIA people call the open call the CIO
call the CTO called a policy person you
know you just if you call the other side
of the shop you might be very lucky so
there's you know so that that's not a
that's not fully an answer the truth is
that you got a you got to work the
system and what's happening so I just
literally submitted a grant proposal to
say to a funder to say we've been doing
all this great training with all these
chief innovation officer chief
technology as we have chief data
scientists in places they get it but
we're not teaching the lawyers and by
the way it's one of the reasons I'm back
here at my alma mater on my home bases
and I'm at the engineering school and my
you but you know it's the lawyers who
actually need to be brought along for
the ride because they are you themselves
rightly as the safeguards of due process
as the safeguard is the public trust but
you know what the world is moving on in
terms of understanding openness by the
way we just did a hue
say a huge report on openness in the
procure others in the grant making
process trying to push grant innovations
lots of people on board but the lawyers
are like hunt what so it's we're
catching them by surprise by not
training those people and bringing them
as part of the conversation so the FDA
is a very as you know mixed peg I've
been working with the FDA for a very
very long time we made a lot of progress
on opening up some data jot when Josh
was there and I worked on creating a
transparency initiative FDA we got some
data out sadly he left my last right now
we're working on another piece of things
which I'll just mentioned put it on your
radar screen is one of the big problems
we've seen a lot of these places is data
readiness so in its again it's like
people don't get what to do with the
data internal to government so yeah you
have a dengue forecasting project at HHS
which is very sophisticated in terms of
let's use predictive analytics to spot
dengue but in most I'm working with the
NHS in England a huge organization
opening up a lot of its data you know
how many people they have who have the
title of analyst or anything to a data
in there to 150 people in an
organization that has millions in it so
now there's a lot of talent that's
hiding in plain sight but you don't have
people in decision-making roles who even
begin to understand what the value is of
data or how to use it it's a very mixed
bag the Commerce Department here has 30
data scientists sitting at the top to
the right of the secretary other
agencies they they don't know from data
so it's partly you know the FDA has its
own very significant challenges in terms
of the outside lobbying on it but in
part there's a lot of work to be done
culturally in terms of bringing the no
machine APA the lawyers and the
procurement people along for the ride
finding the people who are data savvy
and putting them in key roles so I think
the talent is a big piece of it so I
think there's there's work that can be
done I would not however put a lot of
money on the next administration but we
may be pleasantly surprised if we keep
telling them that open data creates jobs
that we can keep in the
maybe we can have some successes but I
put my money on Mexico right now and
Canada for open data I don't mean an un
moving there but open unopened Dana
they're both better than we are at the
moment well thank you for two very good
presentations my question is to bet in
your experience in government what is
the current status or did you ever have
any conversations about making text
return data open what's the status there
and second of when data are gathered
through socio economic processes as
opposed to mechanical automatic
processes you concern yourself with a
trade-off between openness of data and
the quality of data deterioration of the
data Oh tax tax data I have a great
success story to report that will
surprise you I hope so not the story
you're actually asking me about but non
profit tax return data I know you want
individual you want to about individual
taxes let me say on the individual tax
return side I think the question has to
do with providing me back my own data so
it's the story of what a destra net
Cornell Tech called small data if you're
Nigel Shadbolt at Southampton you call
it my data so processes of creating open
data my data that you give back to me
whether it's my health care record in my
tax return I would say they are the IRS
is at zero where we have made progress
is on the non profit tax return front so
by law nonprofits like Yale fired file
their 990s with the government the
federal level in the state level and
those tax returns by law are supposed to
be made open now the openness that they
were providing previously was if you
electronically filed your returns the
IRS would print them out scan them back
in and then put that image file on a DVD
and once a year for twenty thousand
dollars you could buy that DVD I'm going
to fast forward a lot of pain personally
suffered to say that now you can
download that data from the Amazon Cloud
hooray the other part of that story
which is unfolding as we speak is that
the 12 states are working together to
pilot a one-stop filing system so
instead of me to go to every single
state in which you operate you go to one
website click click click click click
file your returns and then that data
will be made automatically open we by
the way are making companies like
guidestar a little unhappy and people
who have whose business model who are
like the apple itunes of tax returns but
they're adjusting and they'll live and
they'll provide value-added services
that are not about selling the data so
there is a very happy news there for the
story about how we actually track tax
data I would point you to the work of a
scholar named Julia Lane an economist
who's now moved to NY you from Chicago
this year who's done a lot of work on
creating at getting accents combining
grants data tax data census data so that
we can actually track the value of
government investment in science so if
the government gives a dollar to Yale
for science we should be able to know
and tax return data is essential to that
what the economics of downstream
economic impact is of those investments
in science so that's again a story about
data act you know the Fifty Shades of
Grey it's not about open data but about
responsible access to data they were
making some progress on by virtue of
having put some innovation rolls into
the IRS I think there's a lot and the
last part of this story is commitments
that are abroad primarily around opening
up beneficial corporate beneficial
ownership data which is partly coming
from tax returns which is knowing who's
the real owner of a company UK has made
progress on this front and other
countries are trying to move forward on
actually trying to tell us who owns who
owns the companies that we do business
with which is a huge yeah no no
nope no progress zero nothing to say I
mean there's no I mean even access i
mean the IRS has a statistical division
that does pull samples of the tax data
in order to do statistical work I would
say there's been no investment of
progress on this front I mean there's a
desire just to simplify the forms that
we fill out and to create simpler you
know tax filing systems or even to
create a default like they have in other
countries where the government
automatically filed my tax return and
then I correct it but we've made no
progress on this does anybody else have
a better news to report them I thought I
had happy night happy news on some
fronts and I will be briefer in my
response nice apologies hi how are you
thank you very much for that Chad I'm
the ulema graduate student of school of
Forestry I wanted to ask you about why
are your thoughts about the openness of
data from government but not only about
the raw data they use for the
policy-making but also about the methods
they use and how can organizations like
the open data open government
partnership can actually encourage this
in not only the United States but in
other governments that might be also
producing data but at the same time
getting to know how they actually use
them to provide public policy so there
are in terms of things like so there are
efforts in sectors so things like the
open contracting partnership are working
to help standardize you know to help
governments know how to publish their
data they're contracting data and how to
standardize that data there are working
groups that are more technical that are
focused on things like data quality and
data standards including you know
there's a group that was stood up called
the open data Institute out of the UK
which is co-chaired by Nigel Shadbolt
and sir tim berners-lee though they and
they do a bit of this work trying to
help governments with their data
practices I think partly what's
happening is a move
spurred by hiring a White House level
chief data scientist we're trying to
create a community of data scientists in
government so Commerce for example has
been in the lead and trying to provide
then guidance and training for other
agencies as you see people start to
replicate creating data savvy roles
within agencies but there really is a
tremendous shortage we see a tremendous
shortage in the private sector of people
with data science training everybody's
clamoring for data scientists oh thank
goodness Yale has has this long list of
things that's getting started but to the
extent to which we can encourage some of
those people to go do work or at least a
tour of duty with the public sector I
think it's incredibly important because
you know right now we have to rely on
the fact that we're putting out data
that often it's of extremely low quality
that's poorly collected and we also
don't know you know forgetting about the
fact that the methods that we use to
analyze that data are still very nascent
I was last week at the launch in
Imperial College of the new center for
the mathematics of precision healthcare
which is simply about developing the
mathematical models and methods that can
be then applied to looking at healthcare
data if I'm you know it's a group of
mathematicians working with clinicians
and so I think we have a very long way
to go we particularly have a long way to
go because of the talent gap that we see
in government's own pockets of work and
happy to share more by email but at the
one of the big let me just say that the
big challenge is when it continues to be
work that's done by if it's done by
diplomats we don't get very far and then
one layer down and the policymakers but
we need those policymakers to be people
who actually are have some data science
training so next month we're going to
launch a course an online free MOOCs
called data analytical thinking aimed at
mid-level government officials who don't
know anything about data precisely to
discuss to help bring people along for
the ride
thank professors know that control
[Applause]